Voy a hablar de un fallo intuitivo
que muchos sufrimos.
En realidad es la capacidad de detectar cierto tipo de peligro.
Describiré una situación que creo que es tan aterradora como posible
y veremos que eso no es una buena combinación.
Y sin embargo, en lugar de sentir miedo,
la mayoría pensará que es algo bastante interesante.
Describiré cómo los avances en el campo de la inteligencia artificial,
en última instancia, podrían destruirnos.
Y, de hecho, me resulta muy difícil ver
que no nos destruirían o nos ayudaran a destruirnos.
Y sin embargo, si son como yo,
encontrarán que es divertido pensar en estas cosas.
Y esta manera de ver las cosas es parte del problema.
Esa reacción debería preocuparles.
Si tuviera que convencerles con esta charla
de que estamos al borde de sufrir una hambruna a nivel mundial,
debido al calentamiento global o cualquier otra catástrofe,
y que sus nietos o sus bisnietos,
vivirán muy probablemente así,
no pensarían:
"Interesante.
Me gusta esta charla TED".
El hambre no es divertida
La muerte en la ciencia ficción, por el contrario, es algo divertido,
y lo más preocupante en el desarrollo de la IA hoy en día
es que parecemos incapaces de ofrecer una respuesta emocional adecuada
frente a los peligros que se avecinan.
Yo mismo soy incapaz de ello y estoy dando esta charla.
Es como si nos encontráramos ante dos puertas.
Detrás de la puerta número uno
detenemos el progreso de máquinas inteligentes.
Nuestro hardware y software se estancan simplemente, por alguna razón.
Traten de reflexionar por un momento por qué podría suceder esto.
Dada la valía de la inteligencia y la automatización,
seguiremos mejorando nuestra tecnología si es posible.
¿Qué podría impedirnos hacer eso?
¿Una guerra nuclear a gran escala?
¿Una pandemia mundial?
¿El impacto de un asteroide?
¿El hecho que Justin Bieber podría ser el presidente de los EE.UU.?
(Risas)
El caso es que algo tendría que destruir la civilización tal como la conocemos.
Realmente deberíamos imaginar algo terrible
para dejar de desarrollar nuestra tecnología
para siempre,
generación tras generación.
Casi por definición, sería lo peor
en la historia humana.
La única alternativa,
y esto es lo que hay detrás de la puerta número dos,
es seguir mejorando nuestras máquinas inteligentes
año tras año tras año.
En algún momento construiremos máquinas más inteligentes que nosotros,
y una vez que las tengamos
empezarán a mejorarse a sí mismas.
Y entonces corremos el riesgo teorizado por el matemático IJ Good
llamado "explosión de inteligencia"
donde el proceso podría salirse de control.
Esto es a menudo caricaturizado, como lo he hecho aquí,
como el miedo a que nos ataquen ejércitos de robots maliciosos.
Pero ese no es el escenario más probable.
No es que nuestras máquinas se volverán malignas espontáneamente.
La preocupación verdadera
al construir máquinas mucho más competentes que nosotros
es que la menor diferencia entre sus objetivos y los nuestros
nos podría destruir.
Basta con pensar en nuestra relación con las hormigas.
No las odiamos.
No vamos por la vida lastimándolas.
De hecho, a veces nos tomamos la molestia de no hacerles daño.
Evitamos pisarlas en la acera.
Pero cada vez que su presencia entra seriamente en conflicto
con alguno de nuestros objetivos,
digamos, en la construcción de un edificio como este,
las aniquilamos sin escrúpulos.
La preocupación es que algún día construyamos máquinas
que, ya sea conscientemente o no,
nos puedan tratar con una indiferencia similar.
Sospecho que esto pueda parece inverosímil para muchos.
Apuesto a que hay quienes dudan de que la superinteligente IA sea posible
y mucho menos inevitable.
Pero en este caso hay que refutar uno de los siguientes supuestos.
Y hay solo tres.
La inteligencia es el procesamiento de información en un sistema físico.
En realidad, esto es poco más que una suposición.
Ya hemos incorporado inteligencia limitada en nuestras máquinas,
y aún así, muchas de estas máquinas actúan a un nivel de inteligencia sobrehumana.
Y sabemos que la mera materia da lugar a lo que se llama "inteligencia general",
la capacidad de pensar con flexibilidad en múltiples campos
porque nuestros cerebro humano ya lo ha conseguido.
Es decir, solo hay átomos aquí,
y mientras continuemos construyendo sistemas de átomos
que exhiban un comportamiento más y más inteligente,
terminaremos implementando, a menos que lo interrumpamos, inteligencia general
en nuestras máquinas.
Es crucial comprender que la velocidad no es el problema
porque cualquier velocidad es suficiente para llegar al fin.
No necesitamos la ley de Moore para continuar ni un aumento exponencial.
Solo tenemos que seguir adelante.
El segundo supuesto es que vamos a seguir adelante.
Vamos a seguir mejorando nuestras máquinas inteligentes.
Y teniendo en cuenta el valor de la inteligencia,
es decir, la inteligencia es o bien la fuente de todo lo que valoramos
o la necesidad por preservar todo lo que valoramos.
Es nuestro recurso más valioso.
Por eso lo queremos hacer.
Tenemos problemas que necesitamos desesperadamente resolver.
Queremos curar enfermedades como el Alzheimer y el cáncer.
Queremos entender los sistemas económicos.
Queremos mejorar el clima.
Vamos a hacer esto, si podemos.
El tren ya salió de la estación y no hay frenos.
Por último, no estamos en la cima de la inteligencia,
ni siquiera cerca, probablemente.
Y esto realmente es crucial.
Esto es lo que hace nuestra situación tan precaria,
y esto es lo que hace que nuestras intuiciones
sobre los riesgos sean poco fiables.
Piensen en la persona más inteligente que jamás haya vivido.
En la lista de casi todos está John Von Neumann.
La impresión que hacía Von Neumann en las personas a su alrededor,
incluyendo los más grandes matemáticos y físicos de su época,
está bastante bien documentada.
Si solo la mitad de las historias sobre él fueran una verdad a medias,
no hay duda
de que es una de las personas más inteligentes que ha vivido.
Así que consideren el espectro de la inteligencia.
Aquí tenemos a John Von Neumann.
Y aquí estamos tú y yo.
Y luego tenemos un pollo.
Lo sentimos, una gallina.
No hay por qué hacer esta charla más deprimente de lo que ya es.
(Risas)
Sin embargo, parece muy probable que el espectro de la inteligencia
se extienda mucho más allá de lo que actualmente concebimos,
y si construimos máquinas más inteligentes que nosotros,
muy probablemente explorarán este espectro
de maneras que no podemos imaginar,
y nos superarán de maneras inimaginables.
Y es importante saber que esto es cierto solo debido a la velocidad.
Así que imaginen que acabamos de construir una IA superinteligente
que no fuera más inteligente
que el promedio del equipo de investigadores en Stanford o el MIT.
Los circuitos electrónicos funcionan
aproximadamente un millón de veces más rápido que los bioquímicos,
así que esta máquina debe pensar un millón de veces más rápido
que las mentes que la construyeron.
Con una semana funcionando
llevará a cabo 20 000 años de trabajo intelectual a nivel humano,
semana tras semana tras semana.
¿Cómo podríamos siquiera comprender, mucho menos restringir,
una mente que progresa de esta manera?
Algo más que es francamente preocupante
es imaginar el mejor de los casos.
Imaginemos que diseñamos una IA superinteligente
que no tiene problemas de seguridad.
Tenemos el diseño perfecto a la primera.
Es como si nos dieran un oráculo
que se comporta exactamente como se espera.
Esta máquina sería el dispositivo de ahorro de mano de obra perfecta.
Puede diseñar la máquina que puede construir la máquina
que pueda hacer cualquier trabajo físico,
impulsada por la luz solar,
más o menos por el costo de las materias primas.
Estamos hablando del fin del trabajo pesado humano.
También estamos hablando del fin de la mayoría del trabajo intelectual.
Entonces, ¿qué harían simios como nosotros en estas circunstancias?
Pues, podríamos jugar al Frisbee y darnos masajes.
Tomar un poco de LSD e inventar modas ridículas
y todo el mundo podríamos parecernos a un festival de rock.
(Risas)
Puede parecer muy bueno, pero hay que preguntarse
qué pasaría con nuestro orden económico y político actual.
Podríamos presenciar
un nivel de desigualdad de la riqueza y el desempleo
nunca antes visto
sin la voluntad de poner esta nueva riqueza inmediatamente
al servicio de toda la humanidad,
y unos poco trillonarios estarían en las portadas de las revistas de negocios
mientras que el resto del mundo tendría la libertad de morirse de hambre.
Y ¿qué pasaría si los rusos o los chinos se enteraran
de que alguna empresa en Silicon Valley
está a punto de crear una IA superinteligente?
Esta máquina podría ser capaz de hacer la guerra,
ya sea terrestre o cibernética,
con un poder sin precedentes.
En este escenario el ganador se lleva todo.
Seis meses adelante en la competencia
sería una ventaja de 500 000 años,
como mínimo.
Parecería que incluso meros rumores de este tipo de avance
podría causar que nuestra especie se vuelva loca.
Una de las cosas más aterradoras,
en mi opinión, en este momento,
son el tipo de cosas que dicen los investigadores de IA
cuando quieren tranquilizarnos.
Y el motivo invocado más frecuentemente de que no nos preocupemos es el tiempo.
Falta mucho para eso, no se preocupen.
Eso será probablemente dentro de 50 o 100 años.
Un investigador dijo,
"Preocuparse por la seguridad y todo lo relacionado con la IA
es como preocuparse por la superpoblación en Marte".
Esta es la manera de Silicon Valley de mostrarse condescendiente.
(Risas)
Nadie parece darse cuenta
que tomar el tiempo con referencia
es una incongruencia total.
Si la inteligencia es solo una cuestión de procesamiento de la información
y seguimos mejorando nuestras máquinas,
produciremos algún tipo de superinteligencia.
Y no tenemos idea de cuánto tiempo nos llevará crear las condiciones
para hacerlo de forma segura.
Voy a decirlo de nuevo.
Y no tenemos idea de cuánto tiempo nos llevará crear las condiciones
para hacerlo de forma segura.
Y si no lo han notado, 50 años ya no son lo que solían ser.
Estos son 50 años en meses.
Este es el tiempo que hemos tenido el iPhone.
Este es el tiempo que "Los Simpson" ha estado en la televisión.
Cincuenta años no es tanto tiempo
para lograr uno de los mayores desafíos al que nuestra especie se ha enfrentado.
Una vez más, parece que no tenemos una respuesta emocional adecuada
para lo que, con toda probabilidad, va a pasar.
El científico de la computación Stuart Russell ofrece una gran analogía:
"Imaginen que recibimos un mensaje de una civilización extraterrestre que diga:
'Gente de la Tierra,
llegaremos en su planeta en 50 años.
Prepárense'".
¿Estaremos contando los meses hasta que llegue la nave nodriza?
¿No estaríamos un poco más preocupados?
Otra razón que se nos da para no preocuparnos
es que estas máquinas no podrán no compartir nuestros valores
porque van a ser literalmente extensiones de nosotros mismos.
Se injertarán en nuestro cerebro,
y prácticamente seremos su sistema límbico.
Consideren por un momento
que el camino más seguro y prudente hacia adelante,
el recomendado,
es la implantación de esta tecnología directamente en nuestro cerebro.
Ahora bien, esto puede ser de hecho,
la manera más segura y prudente de avanzar,
pero por lo general, los problemas de seguridad de una nueva tecnología
hay que resolverlos antes de implementarla en una cabeza.
(Risas)
El mayor problema es
que construir una IA superinteligente y autónoma parece más fácil
que diseñar una IA superinteligente
mientras se controla la neurociencia
para integrar la máquina y la mente sin problemas.
Y dado que las empresas y los gobiernos que trabajan sobre ello
probablemente se vean a sí mismos en una carrera contra todos los demás,
y tomando en cuenta que ganar esta carrera es ganar el mundo,
siempre y cuando no lo destruyan en el momento siguiente,
entonces parece probable que lo más fácil de hacer
se hará primero.
Ahora, por desgracia, no tengo una solución a este problema,
además de recomendarles que piensen más sobre ello.
Creo que necesitamos un Proyecto Manhattan
sobre el tema de la inteligencia artificial.
No para construirlo, porque creo que eso es inevitable,
sino para entender cómo evitar una carrera armamentística
y construirla de manera que concuerde con nuestros intereses.
Cuando hablamos de IA superinteligente
que puede modificarse a sí misma,
solo tenemos una oportunidad de fijar las condiciones iniciales correctas,
e incluso entonces necesitaremos gestionar
las consecuencias económicas y políticas de dicho diseño.
Pero en el momento en que admitamos
que el procesamiento de la información es la fuente de la inteligencia,
que algún sistema computacional adecuado es la base de la inteligencia,
y admitamos que los vamos a mejorar de forma continua,
y admitamos que el horizonte del conocimiento supera por mucho
lo que actualmente conocemos,
entonces tenemos que admitir
que estamos en el proceso de construir una especie de dios.
Ahora sería un buen momento
para asegurarse de que sea un dios con el que podamos vivir.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)